It gives me no pleasure to
bring this to you today.
It's a milestone that we've been
warning about for months at this point,
and it's a horrible milestone as coronavirus
cases and subsequently deaths have climbed.
We hit 2000 deaths per day again and we went past
that. I've been saying that by the end of this
month, we will likely be seeing a 9/11 day worth
of deaths every single day from coronavirus. And
we are essentially there. Yesterday was the worst
single death day since the start of the pandemic.
Twenty eight hundred thirty three people died in
one day. Depending on how you measure the day,
the exact 24 hours, Johns Hopkins actually has a
higher number above three thousand. But this is
roughly, essentially the number of people killed
on 9/11 directly by the events. Now, the number,
it's twenty nine, seventy seven, I believe, is
the official number of 9/11 deaths on 9/11. Now,
this doesn't include people that died in the
days after due to stress induced heart attacks
and and first responders who later developed
illness because of their presence at Ground Zero.
So the number is really quite a bit higher. But
on the day of 9/11, at the sites of the disaster,
it's considered to be just under three
thousand. And that's where we are. We are likely
to significantly exceed this daily death
number for much of the remaining month.
And half the country is barely willing to
alter their lives in any way as a result.
And 9/11 is an interesting event to think about
because think back to 9/11. We as a result of one
day of 3000 people tragically dying, completely
reformed airport security, and created a massive,
I mean gargantuan infrastructure through which
we now all go when we fly. TSA was created,
the Patriot Act was passed justifying invasions
of privacy on the basis of keeping us safe.
We attacked a country and got involved in a multi
decade military engagement. The wrong country,
by the way, we, I believe, also created
the Department of Homeland Security,
may be another agency, all because of 9/11. And
now we have a 9/11 every day at this point, 300000
approaching 300000 dead nationally from
the entire pandemic. And nearly half the
country doesn't want to do anything about this
nine elevens worth of deaths every single day.
Now, as a reminder, covid deaths, lag cases. At
this point, it's by about a month. We are now at
about 100000 people hospitalized nationally with
the virus. That's a record, which means that the
next month is going to be absolutely insane. And
as you can see, when you look at a chart of cases
of those hospitalized and deaths, you see
hospitalizations are approaching nearly double
the record we had. We had about sixty thousand
hospitalizations during the first spike in April.
We had about sixty thousand hospitalized in the
second spike in July. We are now at about one
hundred thousand hospitalized and continuing to
climb. Notice how deaths track hospitalizations.
In the second spike, deaths didn't climb as much,
and that's because hospitals had more capacity. We
are now starting to see hospitals fill up again
and it all bodes really, really poorly. Now
we're expecting vaccine approval for one vaccine
next week, another vaccine shortly thereafter.
It will take months to roll that out. The numbers
we might see in the rest of December into January,
into February, even into March, depending on how
quickly these vaccines are deployed, these are
going to be completely nightmarish numbers.
We're almost living in two realities. Sadly,
you look at what public health experts say and we
have a dire, disastrous situation. You look at the
Instagram and Facebook pages of nearly half the
country, people behaving like nothing is going on.
It is truly nuts. And the next month
is next month is going to be terrible.